a GPS snitch news defacement submitted
by butterface everything's hot but her
face you know what a booby do is nope
tell me when her stomach sticks out
further than her boobie do what happens
it was like Homer Simpson her body looks
like Homer says I saw this tweet that I
thought was a little offensive but I had
me in tears laughing it was his girl in
lingerie a very pretty face but she was
a larger girl and she goes big girls can
be pretty too but somebody will have
comment on this is how can you be fat
and still have no titties I was in tears
laughing but I felt so bad just cuz I
get what she say but that [ __ ] was such
a matter-of-fact Bing too but they're
pretty funny though yeah I have
conscious assassin was betrayed by his
GPS watch I'm going to kill you but also
I need to treat my protein shake really
quick hold on he thought that he was
going a lot further than he thought he
was on his GPS that he was eating
calories more to compensate oh no I
remember his GPS watch he was going on a
jog and I told someone during his jog
he's stalking people he's stalking
factories he's stalking stores he's
assassin so that means that when they
caught him they knew where he went
because of he was tracking his walking
on a GPS yeah yeah running but running
so can you put it all together so my
brain on their side so a British runner
cyclist and mob hit man okay well
they're hot because he was wearing his
GPS watch because he he trains a lot for
marathons and stuff he's wearing his
Garmin it was a Garmin oh wow when he
was doing like a like his one of his
assassination job like no probably
[ __ ] check this status I wanted to
get one like how many calories did I
burn on this [ __ ] murder having like
how many calories did I vote no so he
just spit on it under
he'll give him the banana bread banana
bread mine doesn't taste like banana
yeah she's talking mad [ __ ] about your
banana bread says it's awesome which one
off now I did can I say this right now
so it's a good banana bread or ank you
it's [ __ ] delicious POW it's pretty
good you could probably sell it Thanks
I [ __ ] hate the walnuts but I love I
like it I like walnuts oh yeah a little
piece of walnut came out of this garlic
I'm saying that Apple would have never
snitched on me please sponsor beached on
me please yeah they probably would have
mm-hmm yes oh this guy his name is Mark
ice man fellows there is already nice
nice man don't [ __ ] me come on now
what Top Gun Iseman there's an ice man's
assassin movie well the Iceman is a
serial killer real yeah yeah so many
spills over like 200 people for the mob
Chuck Liddell used to be the Iceman
exactly he had a fatty gun stupid yeah I
call an assassin stupid he's going to
jail he ain't gonna do [ __ ] to me why
because it was watching ya where does he
go kill me look I'm really soft we're
really gonna do [ __ ] so how do they
catch him he was on a run
yeah and they found like you know he
stopped for a sin amount of time he went
on a bike so they found out like oh he
was going to certain miles miles per
hour yeah and then he gets the
destination which is where he shot this
gang this mob boss so in the middle of
his recycling he pulls over and then he
just keeps training it's just part of
his morning workout he got off the bike
he washed yeah to where he shoots this
dude
outside of his home yeah and then he
could walk back to his bike in the bleep
so they could see and the Garmin the GPS
and it tells you like how fast you were
going at what time exactly to me yeah
where you are like you know the GPS a
Garmin loadout that model
is that what you want to be Hector so
this murder was look at me yeah I was
unsolved from 2015 but then they ended
up investigating him and then they came
across a photo of him wearing his Garmin
[ __ ] pulled up they subpoenaed the
records no they searched his home and
they found the watch and they checked
the GPS data and they were able to link
him he also killed someone else of
course is a hit man yeah but he does
during his training to decoy he's
keeping his heart rate of it you know
it's funny so he's not that smart
because this dude in one of the murders
he went over to this dude well he was
wearing this hive eyes I guess I'm
thinking I miss that best and he just
had a gun he was like yeah he didn't
think anyone was gonna report him like
actual witnesses while he was training
with a gun well he's training with his
gun but he was actually shooting someone
with the gun he had it on him you know
what that's so scary like I'm still
processing the fact that there are
actual hitmen in this one yeah that's so
[ __ ] scary because whedon I know of
this but hearing it like in a story like
this is a little frightening yeah and
he's so used to murder that he needs to
track his steps to make sure that he's
burning enough calories they worded this
was so he did not consider witnesses
would notice they cycle he's wearing
both commando gear and a high vis safety
vest while toting a gun he's not very
smart I've got a [ __ ] gun hands are
so cold I wonder how much it is to kill
a person like to hire someone to kill a
person I see like five grand no
absolutely not that's so low is it at
least in the ten twenty and it could be
ten guy depends on the person where
they're from how good they are yeah I
guarantee you someone really wanted some
crap cheap you could probably give it to
you can [ __ ] get somebody killed for
a prepper like a pro like how much is it
for like a Russian Pro right now I'm the
assassin right it's like three hundred
dollars right cuz I'm gonna do it with
the lead pipe with my fingerprints on it
if he had he had guns you know I mean so
that price is gonna be way different if
you want to get the discount version
like me
there's a high chance you might get
caught but I'm a good deal I'm talking
like I want like Keanu Reeves Liam
Neeson's going after in killing people
for all we love Liam Neeson's to kill
some are like they put the poison
lipstick on and then they kiss them and
then later they give themselves the
[ __ ] antidote and not them and then
they die now we're getting crazy like a
really seductive poison ivy oh my god
the words [ __ ] kiss me
[ __ ] Cuse me I denied for like in the
movies how much do you cost to be a
human being that could just take
somebody's life away just for like some
money just sent out on a jog shows that
you're a psychopath right oh yeah to do
photo that's right I have to kill
someone
boom boom shakin Stein dude don't even
look like a killer dude was that him
well see there's a random jogger what do
you do like all they do mention that
they were really killed so that they
were looking into a marathon runner by
the same name in the same age group and
they found a different runner that
actually matches that but this other
runner he's actually it's ironic because
he's a lawyer who also was kind of crazy
because they share the same name same
age group same love for running but
completely different person likes to
kill and one people like to assume now
the lawyers gonna represent the killer
Oh Shane dude it's cool that this hitman
is actually responsible and he trains
and stuff sometimes like in those
Italian seen a fat hit man have you yeah
like those Italian movies they do hire a
guy and then I looked at that dude on
screen oh my mana fighters ran away from
those guys guys didn't catch me hmm he
would have done a better job if he was
really fat though like he's known about
it
I just sitting there and you see
somebody comes up you just eating a hot
dog and then ice comes up hot dog I
would never suspect that guy in the
movies assassins like that job is so
cool mm-hmm yeah but in real life kind
of messy there's a serial killer just
got caught recently people really he
killed a bunch of gay people but he
looks like he was a mall Santa oh Lord
Wow
like the nicest he was a he was a
gardener I think people forget that
these killers are also people too with
hobbies like some of what might have pet
fish he put them they have all kinds of
feelings you know like how can he be a
murderer he's like pet fish it's like
they kill they play of hobbies you know
like they what else are they doing like
when they're not killing yes right there
eating sandwiches they're [ __ ] going
and being mall Santas or the lamps or
with the little girl who oh you're
talking about the Black Swan chick she
was a little girl oh yeah what's that
movie I know
mr. mrs. deeds yeah what's the one with
Angelina Julia mr. Boozman mr. deeds
movie that's a molester movie huh loud
mr. mrs. deeds the Adam Sandler movie /
mr. mrs. oh my bad dude it's [ __ ]
Smith that's right yeah a serial killer
guy was a was a landscaper and he would
put the body parts in the potted plants
on his clients really good yeah cuz they
needs that kind of food that's people so
far that they found yeah that's so crazy
makes me wonder how many people get away
with action I'm seeing a lot of people
do do you ever drive by like Vegas fuels
and stuff like Dan there might be so
many bodies bigger the mountain mm-hmm
dump I think the best [ __ ] when wearing
wherever we're at Griffith Park
yeah it looks scary I wash I excuse
serial killer shows the stuff like that
you get scared there at home by yourself
I love myself too much to torture myself
like that the recent one I'm watching is
the assassination of Versace oh yes I
didn't know he was assassinated because
I thought Versace was always the lady it
was outside his house met his sister I
just don't know but I thought that was
always the Versace I thought Versace was
always the Donatella that invented
everything
mm-hmm I had no idea was a man should be
so important to be assassinated he's
already killed me he's just like I just
got killed
no one's gonna fascinate me it's just I
just got killed if I get killed I'm just
gonna that's what like the seals and the
Special Forces guys are for they're all
out there just taking out head leaders
of different governments and
organizations and stuff say see it's
crazy verse AC
[Music]